[Music]
today we this morning we're going to
talk about computation and the
transformation of the life sciences and
it's transforming many things here at
MIT one thing is our educational system
for example we recently announced a
joint program at the undergraduate level
between computer science and biology
which is extraordinarily exciting and
our speakers are going to provide
different insights into the aspects of
how computation is really influencing
life sciences here it might be broadly
construed so I'm very pleased to
introduce Eric Lander who's a professor
here biology at MIT professor of systems
biology at Harvard and the founding
director of the Broad Institute please
welcome Eric
[Applause]
well thanks Dave can you hear me
excellent
I'm just delighted to be doing this a
hundred and fifty years at MIT Wow
I have been at MIT since 1985 in one
form or another so about 25 years or so
or rather terrifyingly one-sixth of the
span of MIT somehow that concerns me I
want to talk about as part of your
transformation of practically everything
the transformation of genetics the
transformation in a very deep and
fundamental way of life sciences I can
think of
here's a picture to start off with these
are chromosomes viewed in the microscope
biologists reveled in looking down the
microscope at things you know they
didn't know what the things were these
are chromosomes which since they had no
idea what they were when they were
discovered but they stained with the dye
were called colored things meaning that
his chromosomes I'll just just love
details when I was in high school I
hated biology because it just seemed
like it was tons of details there were
no general principles indeed as a high
school student and as a college student
and getting my own PhD I was a
mathematician I got my PhD in
mathematics and algebraic combinatorics
and never imagined that I would be
interested in biology because I just
didn't go in for all of these fussy
details when a biologist wanted to study
a disease Oh heart disease brain
degeneration bowel disorders autoimmune
diseases you had to be an expert in the
heart the brain the bowel or the immune
system there is nothing general nothing
generic now of course we know the great
power of mathematics and computation is
the general being able to see all things
is essentially the same thing from the
right perspective where did that how did
that change in biology that is the story
of what has changed in biology over the
course of the last thirty years or so
is biology has become in a very deep way
about information and that has changed
everything about biology including
building extraordinary ties between the
biological sciences and at MIT and the
computational sciences it's not better
Illustrated than by looking at the
Whitehead Institute built in the early
1980s by one of the greatest biologists
of the second half of the 20th century
David Baltimore when he designed the
Whitehead Institute in around 1983 there
was absolutely no provision whatsoever
for computers at the last minute they
scrambled to put in a little mainframe
room on the second floor but they never
imagined that computers would matter
next to it stands the Broad Institute
built sometime later about 25 years
later which I direct and roughly half of
what the Broad Institute does is
computational and no serious
card-carrying genomicists today would
not have reasonable training in the
computational sciences it's a total sea
change now how did this come about well
the generic it came about with the
understanding that there were generic
approaches you could take well actually
there was an old generic approach dating
back to 1913 and fruit fly genetics that
made it possible to trace the
inheritance of a disease in a family it
was a family of fruit flies in 1913
where you would trace one trade in
another trade and if they showed Co
inheritance you could say that the two
genes that caused them that must be
nearby it was a mathematical inference
you could draw but you couldn't really
do this for human beings until a little
bit of DNA sequencing technology came
along because you couldn't make crosses
between humans and you couldn't follow
traits like curly wings and funny
bristles and all that but you could
follow DNA spelling differences and if
you found a DNA spelling difference such
as is shown here where dad is passing it
on to four of his eight children and it
tracks along with the disease that's
also passing in the family and you saw
that for enough families
you could eventually conclude that
whatever caused the DNA spelling there
that whatever caused the disease was in
fact nearby on one of the chromosomes to
one of those spelling differences that
was an abstract inference that you could
make regardless of whether is a heart
disease a brain degeneration or whatever
you therefore knew you were close by you
could then use that piece of DNA get the
next piece in da next piece next piece
next piece next piece of DNA in an
unbelievably boring process called
chromosomal walking I come from Brooklyn
I call it chromosomal schlepping it took
five years five years to go from A Link
to net ik marker that showed 99%
correlation to actually isolating the
gene for cystic fibrosis ha but when you
got there you were rewarded with this
lots of letters well those three letters
CT T that are deleted are deleted on the
vast majority of chromosomes with cystic
fibrosis this gene is the cause of
cystic fibrosis this particular mutation
is the most common cause and you could
test people very quickly by
amplification reactions to see who's a
carrier not only that you could learn
what this gene does without having any
prior knowledge by computing you could
take the sequence of the gene throw it
into a computer and ask the computer to
do a kind of strength do a string
comparison is the string of amino acids
encoded by this gene similar to by some
definition any other gene you'd seen
before and bingo it's it was similar to
dozens of other genes that encoded
proteins sat in the membrane and
transported things back and forth
congratulations you've probably found
the transporter gene you're handed a
hypothesis on a silver platter whereas
the official biological path was to wait
five or six years to somehow stumble
into hypothesis randomly you now had a
hypothesis generator of enormous power
well of course the power of that
hypothesis generator depended on how
much data there was in there there was a
network effect the more that was in
there the more you could learn the more
you could learn about other things now
the problem with the story I've just
told you was this took five years it
took about tens of millions of dollars
hundreds of people to get one
cystic fibrosis oh yeah that's you know
too much work that was the purpose of
the human genome project it was to begin
to generate data on a much more
efficient rapid large scale so we could
collect all these data and then to
increase the the tools to improve the
tools for being able to do this kind of
work to make genetic maps of those
spelling differences that you could use
to trace inheritance physical maps of
all the DNA so you wouldn't have to
schlep up and down the chromosomes
yourself all the sequence maps so you
could just double click on a region and
see what was there gene lists so you
would already know how to parse up where
the genes were and to make sure all the
information was totally freely available
to everybody without restriction the
Human Genome Project was successful
around 2001 a draft sequence was
published it took about took about 11
years to get to that point about 1314
years to get to a finished sequence that
had virtually the whole thing laid out
with very few errors three billion
nucleotides we had to covering them
about seven fold on average to get
enough coverage about 20 odd billion
nucleotides the data collected whole
world working together and coming down a
learning curve we were so pleased with
ourselves but then what's happened in
the last five or six years is really
breathtaking technology has shifted in a
way that even you guys who work in
computer science would find impressive
all sorts of new machines have come
along to give us a new world of DNA
sequencing and generating data at an
amazing clip machines that do massively
parallel sequencing instead of looking
at DNA sequence on a line through some
little capillary and observing it you
array it out on a slide you can
simultaneously follow many many many
different DNA sequencing reactions all
going on in parallel by optical methods
and here's what it felt like back in
1999 we were so proud of ourselves at
the Broad Institute to have done 1
billion bases of DNA sequence and to get
up to 20 billion bases by the time of
the height of the human genome project
into 70 billion bases by 2006 per year
then the new technologies came along the
next two years look like this
1700 billion bases the next year 19,000
billion bases last year 125,000 billion
bases next this this year probably about
tenfold higher if I put this on a cost
curve of the sort you guys would
recognize Moore's law is shown here on
the log scale sequencing costs are shown
there in red they decreased over the
course of a decade by 100,000 fold
running somewhat fad somewhat twice as
fast as Moore's Law and it ain't done
yet now it will reach some limits this
actually is not going to go on forever
this represents the jumping from one
s-curve to another s-curve enough I have
to confess to an audience like this it
involves exploiting technologies that
were there already for the exploitation
but nonetheless just imagine the feeling
to us when you can begin to say what
experiments could I do now that I
couldn't do ten years ago given that I
can collect data a million times faster
and cheaper boy a lot a lot of amazing
experiments what difference is it making
I just wanna give you a little sense of
what difference it's making the idea of
building these maps of laying out those
spelling differences along the
chromosome and filling in the sequence
and all that it turned out to be a
foundation for so much more because once
you had a first map you could get
fragmentary information from any other
experiment any experiment that could
give you bits of sequence you could
start laying it on the map imagine
Google Maps we can begin populating it
with satellite imagery with imagery
about you know good doughnuts stores
about all sorts of things layered on top
and on top and the top of the map and
the map gets richer you know where your
friends are it gets richer and richer
and richer we can lay it on top of this
map the locations of genes that come
from some experiments evolutionary
conservation across species this
chromatin state whatever that is
inherited variation Maps Disease
Association Maps evolutionary selection
Maps cancer gene maps and that's what's
going on this pile of information is
piling up from so many different sources
and the returns are coming to how do you
integrate that information how do you
make inferences across modalities of
information how do you generate
hypotheses like we did with cystic
fibrosis that you never would have ever
imagined but now
not just from one stream comparison but
from comparisons across thousands of
experiments being done across the world
well what have we learned we've learned
a lot about how to sequence DNA I'm
gonna just briefly sketch very very
briefly what we've learned about the
functional elements encoded in the
genome in this way and every single
thing I'm gonna tell you about relies
crucially on computation you couldn't
even begin to work on the problem
without major computation the functional
elements the evolution of the genome the
basis of inherited disease the basis of
cancer human history I'll just rip
through some stories quickly the details
don't matter but the general sense does
because I want to be sure to leave time
for questions
discovering the functional elements
encoded in the genome how are we gonna
read the sequence and see what's
important genomes are pretty boring
this is genome sequence I mean it's as
exciting as the ones and zeros on your
hard disk right without some way to
parse it the file headers of some sort
ends of files etc it's very hard you
know in principle what we'd like to do
is look at every single letter and see
if it matters by changing it and seeing
if it has an effect change some a to a T
and grow up a new human being that has
that sequence and see if there's any
difference that's considered unethical
and for the most part impractical but
there are there in fact that experiment
has been done it's been run by a certain
sequence
retained
across that time and by comparing the
sequence of the mouse to the sequence of
the human this is just conceptual the
sequence is not written into the English
alphabet you can run code and code will
tell you ha I see hidden messages in the
two sequences and you get into
interesting questions here you know well
how how exact of the matches have to be
what if I have to compare K strings with
a certain degree of mismatch between
them what's the optimal algorithms for
doing this and that etc for sensitivity
for speed etc lots of rich problems
there so it meant we wanted much more
than the human we wanted the mouse so we
got the mouse we wanted the rat and the
dog so we got the mouse and the rat and
the dog in fact we wanted dozens of
mammals and so we now have 40 different
momenta 30 different mammalian genomes
and we've got fishes and we've got all
sorts of things running around and
they're all freely available on the web
lots and lots of information what have
we learn from looking at all this
information from careful computational
analysis of all this information we
learned that we were so far off on how
many genes there are in the genome I
teach MIT students introductory biology
indeed over the last two decades I have
taught about 55% of all MIT students I
calculate in introductory biology and I
taught at least the decade of them that
there were a hundred thousand genes in
the human genome and that's totally
wrong and I'm still you know wracked
with guilt about having misinformed them
about this fact it was in fact by doing
evolutionary comparison computational
analysis we can show there's only 21,000
genes in the genome I can't give you the
argument but I can tell you that that's
about right but we also find that to our
surprise while there are fewer genes is
much more important information
evolution has conserved again a
computation about five or six percent of
the human genome but only one point two
percent encodes proteins so there's tons
of non-coding regulatory information
reversing our picture which before had a
little bit regulation and a lot of
protein coding it's now a little bit of
protein coding and a lot of regulation
and so genes involved in early
development like that red guy down there
at the bottom that's a protein coding
gene in terms involved in early
development it looks like all those
purple things are in
are involved in ensuring that that gene
gets turned on at the right time in the
right place etc now you can go beyond
stuff like this you can ask biologically
how is the DNA controlled by proteins
sitting on top of it you might think oh
I got to do lots of biochemistry but you
do have to do biochemistry the DNA is
wrapped around proteins that are
modified with methyl groups in a settle
groups and other things how am I gonna
find where they hole are well again
large-scale parallel approaches get an
antibody that recognizes any particular
modification pull down the DNA that's
attached to that modification sequence
it lay it on the map and you build
yourself maps maps of this flavor of
modification that flavor modification
that flavor and all the places that have
that modification get pulldown sequenced
and laid out on the map and you can
begin to see things like genes that are
turned on have distinctive signatures
green bits and blue bits here we knew
what to look for genes being turned on
but in fact a recent work done at csail
in fact by my colleague Manolis Kellis
has taken lots of these just chromatin
signatures and an unbiased way asked are
there combinations of signatures that
denote things we never guessed in
biology and there are when you look at
these things you can use them to scan
along the genome CC I see three genes
right now I compare it to my catalog and
say ah that's in the catalog that is
that's not a protein coding gene ah soy
4,000 new genes that don't encode
proteins pop out at you these are the
kinds of returns that come from
computation so a computational graduate
student in my lab discovered 4,000 new
genes by computing pretty cool
well anyway what's more stuff like this
on the basis of disease I told you about
cystic fibrosis a simple Mendelian
disease you trace simply in a family
we're doing pretty well with that almost
3,000 of those have been found so far
the real challenge has been to find the
basis of common diseases polygenic
diseases heart disease Alzheimer's
things that aren't simple one gene
diseases and even as recently as the
year 2000 we only have about 20
five examples that we really knew the
genes but again a generic approach a
computational approach arose in the mid
nineteen and mid 90s several of us
proposed hey you know there's only ten
or 20 million genetic variants that are
common in the human population let's
find them all let's simply test every
one of them in thousands of people with
a disease and see which ones are
enriched in people with a disease and
not people not in people without the
disease simple idea just kind of nuts
you need to be able to find an assay ten
million variants and thousands of people
it's ten billions of genotypes and it's
usually done one at a time and the
students tend to object to doing ten
billion of them so the solution make it
easier databases were fat were created
of the variants genotyping expanded in
speed and today we have the 20 million
variants we can genotype 2 million of
them at a time and we can do all this
and here's what it felt like in terms of
the discovery of genes underlying common
diseases in each of the years 2002 2004
one gene was discovered related to
common diseases 2005 though for 2006 7
2007 2008 9 10 today
1100 low side for more than 165
different common diseases etc similar
things are going on for cancer today I
won't go into the details but by taking
tumors and normals and sequencing them
you can find the mutations that occurred
in the tumor that weren't present and
then match normal tissue begin to
collect them in a recent paper that just
came out here from MIT here and from the
broad six new biological pathways in the
blood cancer multiple myeloma lots of
examples are coming out computationally
like that then finally human history
there is so much historical information
of the human genome that is so fun to
find we had an old story about humans
came out of Africa that's correct
migrated out and split and split and
split into different populations around
the world
and we knew that selection played some
role in all this but we didn't know what
the role was well with the data that's
come along and with computational tools
and stochastic models and all sorts of
rich computation I won't talk about we
know so much more today we know that
it's a story not of just splitting but
tremendous mixing of India being a
mixture of two different populations
coming here Europe lots of mixtures and
my favorite mixture we know that humans
are four percent Neanderthal we can now
read out the Neanderthal mixture in
humans by looking in the and resolved
sequence and comparing it to other
sequences and doing the right stochastic
models and it's very clear we're part
Neanderthal we can read out positive
selection in the human genome
sweeps when something became
advantageous and swept with it a whole
region of the chromosome around it and
more than 300 such regions have been
identified and we can go back and ask
what kind of selections happens in the
speciation of humans from our common
ancestor with chimp and identified genes
dozens of genes that underwent strong
positive selection well what have we
learned we've learned a lot we've
learned specifics about biology
specifics about disease specifics about
evolution specific have key about all
sorts of things but what we've really
learned is a lot about the structure of
biology and about scientific community
we've learned that biology is inherently
about information it's most powerful and
richest when you view it as a form of
information because you can do things
generically and generally and we learned
that to get that information we have to
work together to build common
infrastructure standards ways of talking
to each other and we have to share data
freely in short we've learned a whole
lot of lessons that the world of
computer science already knows and it's
a good thing we have because biology is
well it always still be wet and it
always be looking down a microscope and
all those sort of things that it'll care
about its details biology is now
inexorably inevitably and permanently
about information thanks so much
[Applause]
well thanks Eric for such a wonderful
talk sure we have a question here I was
talking last night to a Cecil graduate
patent attorney at dinner and he was
kind of defending the the sort of use of
intellectual property laws because there
are unlike you know as he conceded there
sort of in applicability to computer
science and that realm areas where it's
very important and it you know you
couldn't do Pharma products you know
without that system how does this sort
of intersect with what you're talking
about because it sounds to me like what
you have is a very open process and it's
dependent on that exactly the Human
Genome Project made a commitment so that
all the data would be open available
without patents without any restrictions
and we felt it was incredibly important
on the other hand I totally defend the
need to have patents on small molecules
that go in a bottle and are subjected to
a hundred million dollars of clinical
testing because if we don't have patents
on that someone else is going to come in
and sell the product therefore nobody
will be incentive to make the investment
essentially it's about what is the
social bargain the social bargain to me
of granting a monopoly on something
where somebody's gonna vest Andreea
billion dollars for clinical trial makes
great sense the social bargain for
information that is cheap and easy to
obtain anybody can get it why do I want
to be handing out monopolies to somebody
who's merely running a sequencer there
so we fought a battle there was a great
battle in the Human Genome Project
between a public and a private version
and the model for the private version
was this would be privatized it would be
private databases where you'd pay to
access and I think you know in computer
science we see the value of integrating
data across so many sources I think
biology has to figure out exactly the
word where to draw those lines the right
way to draw it we say what's the right
bargain to strike societally the law
doesn't do that the law says what's
obvious and inventive and we create
these fictions about what's obvious and
inventive and decide that certain things
we don't want to make a bargain are
aren't really inventive or aren't
obvious and I think we're edging to
trying to get that right you spoke quite
eloquently of all of the things that
we're now learning because of our
ability to mine this information in ways
that we haven't been able
do so and you know you just spoke a
little bit about some of the social
issues of integration and other things I
was wondering if you can speak a moment
or two about the computational and
perhaps other issues that are still on
the table and what the challenges are
for the next generation and maybe that's
a simple hard problem but it's a
fabulous question so you know this past
generation managed to get a lot of
mileage out of linear string comparisons
maybe n strings being compared together
is something the next problem is to go
up one level it's to infer circuitry we
have to reverse-engineer circuitry and
circuitry that wasn't even designed by
some collection of Engineers over the
course of decades but in fact evolved in
a totally opportunistic way over the
course of billions of years how do we
take information that we can read out of
the cell we can read out what genes are
turned on and off how the chromatin has
changed in various ways at increasing
resolution we can go in and we can cut
wires we can interfere with the gene
using RNA interference and other things
we can introduce new genes how do we
take those tools and do reverse
engineering and infer circuitry how do
we exploit evolutionary comparisons
because we know that circuits aren't
invented that often and the new
generation you know faculty like here at
MIT Aviv Regev in the biology department
who's a card-carrying mathematician and
computer scientist she's thinking deeply
about how do you reverse engineer
circuitry those are hard problems
problems for which there aren't even
great answers in computer science and
and in statistics they're great starting
points for that kind of machine learning
but it's machine learning about a very
unusual kind of machine so it's a great
set of problems anybody who's done with
whatever they're doing in computer
science and has a couple spare cycles
and wants to think about these problems
we still the ratio of computer science
needed computer to computer science
available within biology is still way
off the optimum that we have to achieve
I know it's time David thank you
[Applause]
I'm very pleased introduce const oates
who's the Keck professor here at MIT
welcome Colin well first thanks I want
to thank the organizers for inviting me
here to talk about some aspects of
medicine and computation now I guess
when I first heard about this symposium
I thought giving a talk about
computation and a transformation of
Medicine would be a good topic but that
would be a 6-hour endeavor and my area
of expertise is cardiovascular medicine
so I thought it'd be best to focus on
that to put this into some perspectives
starting out from talking about big
things big problems problems about
things which involve things that you can
see with the naked eye and kind of going
down to things that are much more
relevant for the future and discussions
discussions as such so I want to begin
by talking about medicine at the turn of
the century and that basically is about
in 1903 I'd say this picture was taken
from him and parenthetically I'll say I
showed this picture to my wife who's a
psychiatrist that's an important piece
of information and watching her eyes she
looked at the gentleman's face she
looked at his clothes and only
afterwards looked at all of these
contraptions and the buckets filled with
salt water and said well this is clearly
somebody who's about to be electrocuted
for some nefarious crime when in
actuality this is one of the first ECG
recordings right so now this entire
contraption could probably fill a very
expensive but small condominium in the
Back Bay
but it was state-of-the-art at the time
where we could record electrochemical
signals that originated from the heart
and get information about how these
signals are propagated and actually
cardiovascular health and you can
contrast this to any of you who've been
to your physician as of late what
electrocardiogram looks today to see the
difference all because of advances in
both in hardware and in software so now
not only the state of the art at the
turn of the century was was that
electrocardiogram but there were
it was possible to to visualize the
cardiovascular system as well so in vivo
imaging the problem is that that
happened at autopsy so that you need to
die to be able to understand actually
the structures within the heart and if
there was disease and we learned a lot
of important information from these
types of studies we learned about the
blood flow through the heart blood flow
returns to what's called the right
atrium the right heart goes out to the
lungs returns to the left heart the left
agent and left ventricle and out to the
aorta to the rest of the body so very
simple design principles arose from
those studies but those are all what we
call ex vivo post-death now I do many
other things that I can talk about
leeches and other sorts of Voodoo and so
forth that happened at that time but
it's much more interesting to talk about
where we are today now here this is the
electrocardiogram that I showed you
before and this is probably the much
more familiar picture today where all of
those boxes and tubs of salt water and
so forth are replaced by this small
device and we have leaves which we've
replaced the buckets with and in which
we can get much more information about
how the electrical signals are
transmitted through the heart and very
precise information about what areas of
the heart are damaged from looking at
the standard 12-lead electrocardiogram
again all because of advances both on
the software and the hardware side we
can either quiet we can also acquire
this information from people who are
just walking around many of you here may
have actually worn a holter monitor so
this contraption which is here by the
side of the patient is now reduced to
something that's here in the pocket of
this patient and by recording these
impulses over time we can get
information about heart rhythms and
diagnose what we would call arrhythmias
incidences of ischemia where the heart
is not getting enough blood usually due
to atherosclerosis
but the major advance is I should say
coming cardiac imaging and that they can
happen now pre autopsy so this is tight
this is a type of study called an
echocardiogram a cardiac ultrasound and
it's a special type of cardiac
ultrasound called a transesophageal
study and here we get information about
the left age
the valves which control the flow of
blood for the left atrium to the left
ventricle the left heart the right heart
and we can look at the structures and
diagnose disease in this manner
and this involved a lot of you know
increasing signal-to-noise problems in
terms of the software and also many
different hardware problems that had to
be overcome and in addition applying the
simple principles of Doppler shift which
you know originated from a lot of
studies that came from MIT we can look
at flow blood flow across the valves so
here this red flow represents blood
that's going at a relatively high
velocity from the left ventricle to the
left atrium normally blood goes the
opposite way from the left atrium to the
left ventricle so we can diagnose
valvular heart disease this is a leaky
valve and we can do this all prior
non-invasively by standard methods of
and principles of ultrasound we can look
at specific valve fabulus structures to
ensure that they are normal this is the
aortic valve and the aortic valve
normally has we referred to as three
leaflets again all non-invasive studies
parenthetically I would say that this
sign we originally referred to in a
valve is closed as a mercedes-benz sign
but as the as the income of physicians
have devolved it's now referred to as a
peace sign which I thought was sort of
an interesting piece of piece of
information we can take these
two-dimensional images that cut that are
acquired your cardiac ultrasound and
merged them together to get a
three-dimensional image of the heart so
we're advancing now we started out with
an electrocardiograph II and these are
all things that are available routinely
today in the care of patients with
cardiovascular disease we can talk about
cardiac ultrasound with these
two-dimensional images combine them
together to get a 3-dimensional image of
the heart we can slice it in what's
called
sadly that's from the tip here to the
tip here through the base and now we can
slice it in an orthogonal situation to
get a look at specific valvular
structures where this is a look at the
what's called the mitral valve some of
the more impressive changes have come
with cardiac MRI and here unlike the
cardiac ultrasound studies
get very detailed pictures where the
signal-to-noise quality is actually a
lot better here this is we start from
what's called the base of the heart and
we can see the blood flow from the left
ventricle out into the aorta and we can
go down from the base all the way to the
apex and we can look at various regions
of the left ventricle the right
ventricle and all of these pictures so
left ventricle and the right ventricle
and we can get very precise information
about cardiac function fabula function
and these now corresponds to the
standard of care there many other things
that I can talk about but the advances
that have happened over the course of
the last century even if the course of
the last 50 years are pretty profound
there are many studies that we can do
that can give us allow us to diagnose
things that we could never have dreamed
of diagnosing that's at the turn of the
century but I think the most interesting
discussion is where are we going what
are the challenges for the future where
does computation come into play when we
talk about looking at patients and
improving patient care in the future in
this and put this into perspective
cardiovascular disease despite all of
these advances is still a major problem
in 2009 there was a heart attack in the
United States every 30 seconds one in
four deaths are due to cardiovascular
disease it's an enormous cause of
morbidity and mortality and we're still
not hardly very good at it if you look
at all of the patients who've died from
cardiovascular disease we're able to
predict a relatively small number of
them so the goal of cardiovascular
medicine is is really about risk
stratification that is identifying high
risk patients so that you can intervene
in a timely fashion to prevent adverse
outcomes so if you ask someone how to do
this you'd get different answers how do
we improve our ability to risk stratify
patients and some would say well we need
higher resolution MRI scans someone say
we need a non-invasive visualization of
the coronary arteries but can occur via
very good MRI scans or CT scans or other
things that actually cost a whole lot of
money right now it's interesting that
this this I'm standing on is a little
higher than the floor because this I
will view this as my soapbox and use
this as an
opportunity to sort of express some of
my own biases and my own reflections on
where computation can play in the future
of a cardiovascular care so there's a
lot of low costs easily obtained data
like the electrocardiogram that can be
acquired over an extended period of time
that have prognostic value when you go
into your physician and you get an
electrocardiogram or you get an MRI scan
it's called a point-of-care test so you
walk in you may not be feeling well at
that time or your physician for some
reason or another is concerned by
something that you've told him or her
and he says well you know let's go get
that test and then you walk out and you
live your life as as you as you do
and it could be that at the time that
the test is taken you're fine but later
on down the line it could be after
you've left the test that you have
problems and the hypothesis here is that
if you were able to observe patients
looking at easily obtain data heart rate
change it's electrocardiographic data
and so forth you have you'd be able to
better prognosticate so and there are
two parts to this
you've got to obtain data easily and
you've got to be able to analyze it so
you've got sort of an information
problem so there are lots of data that
we could obtain from the patient so here
you see a mature gentleman clutching his
chest about to have a heart attack a
typical sign called the Levine sign in
patients pressure across the tray
chest possibly shortness of breath and
other associated symptoms now as an
outpatient we can obtain
electrocardiographic data we can obtain
blood pressure data we can obtain data
about one's breathing if this patient
were in the hospital we could obtain
continuous blood pressure monitoring we
could contain we could obtain
measurements of pulmonary artery
pressures lots of information that we
can obtain in fact so much information
it's hard for the physician to make
sense of it just by looking at that data
by him or herself so they're what I
refer to this as a macroscopic challenge
we have to obtain and interpret large
amounts of easily obtained data
physiologic data and use it for risk
stratification and I think this is a
place where computation can play a major
role in the future so if we're
contrasting the macroscopic challenge in
with respect to obtaining the data here
I'm going to focus on work that has that
currently going on at at the Institute
so there are devices that can be
designed that are relatively small that
we can actually place on the patient
that can record data we hope in the over
the span of a couple of weeks we can
record motion data with accelerometers
we can record electrocardiographic data
and record information about Oh tuck Oh
to saturations and that is to be
contrasted with the typical halter
monitor now you could imagine wearing
this contraption for a day or two is not
too much of a too much of a hardship but
wearing this stuff for a week two weeks
three weeks as a you know who would want
to do that if you put this song I take
it off after the first three days so the
smaller it is and a more comfortable it
is the more likely that you'll be able
to obtain the data over an extended
period of time that has that has value
for risk stratification we can even get
smaller you can imagine a device and
this is again work that's going on at
the Institute that fits behind the ear
like a hearing aid that records again
electrocardiographic information
information about Oh to saturation and
and to use those data to make very rough
estimates of what's called the cardiac
output how much blood is expelled from
the heart per unit time and this is
where I think things are going and these
are you know this is not I'm talking
about like 50 years down the line I'm
talking about just a few years down the
line so there's gathering the data and I
think that that's sort of largely and in
some sense a hardware problem but
there's interpreting macroscopic data
and there many ways that this can be
done so here I'm gonna give you an
example if I just looked at
electrocardiographic data this is a
normal electric cardiogram and you
usually see this if you turn on the
popular television shows that involve
doctors and I think ER was a popular
show I think when I was in medical in
medical school I don't know what it is
now but a normal electric cardiogram is
actually very informative for several
reasons you have to have a normal
conduction system right and you also
have to have a normal interaction
between the heart and the nervous system
because these two things interact with
one another so if you're watching the
Yankees and Red Sox depending on your
disposition and depending on which game
you watched your heart
may increase a great deal right so it's
supposed to say that actually there are
interactions between these two systems
and a normal electric cardiogram with a
normal heart rate and a normal
morphology is it's actually tells you
quite a bit about each of these
different factors so in using ECG data
for prognostication and this is some of
this work is in collaboration with Zhi
Shan Syed he's a professor at Michigan
and John GU tog here at csail and myself
that subtle B to B changes in a
morphology that's the shape of the ECG
signal over time that can't be detected
by eye because they are so subtle may
have prognostic significance now all the
people are not good at looking at
detecting these changes computers are
and by using sophisticated computer
algorithms it can quantify these b2b
changes in morphology and assess their
prognostic value and so one of these
measures that looks at actually these
b2b changes and quantifies them in a
very sophisticated way is called
morphologic variability and sure enough
if you take a group of patients who've
had a recent cardiovascular event which
you call an acute coronary syndrome or a
myocardial infarction or heart attack
and you look at those patients that have
a high morphologic variability and you
look at their rate of death as a
function of time versus those that have
a low morphologic variability high
morphologic variability by itself
predicts it and almost an eight or nine
fold increased risk of death right with
much of that occurring within the first
30 days post the event so just the
electrocardiographic data by itself
looking at subtle changes using
sophisticated algorithms gives you quite
a bit of information for risk
stratification and that holds true in
many different patient subgroups so if
you are mature or if you are young it
still holds true female smoker nonsmoker
diabetics in the majority of these cases
and this plot the thing to get across is
that points over on this side are
statistically significant increases in
your risk you can also combine
morphologic variability or these types
of measures with established measures of
risk to improve the performance so for
example physicians typically look at
what's called the left ventricular
ejection fraction so that's the amount
of blood that's ejected from the heart
with each beat if the left ventricular
ejection fraction is less than 40% we
say the patients fall into high-risk
subgroups are not increased risk of
adverse events now if you're greater
than 40 presents physicians generally
say okay well you're all right I'm not
going to intervene too much because
you're falling into a low-risk category
but although the risk is lower with
patients that have an ejection fraction
greater than 40 percent most of the
deaths occur in this subgroup so it's
not sufficient to say well okay well
your EF your ejection fraction is
greater than some number and I can leave
you alone
and it turns out that when you combine
morphologic variability measures again
just by looking at electrocardiographic
data using these subtle algorithms you
can improve the performance further so
if you look at patients that fall into
this high-risk subgroup patients that
have an ejection fraction less than 40%
they have higher rates of death but if
your ejection fraction is less than 40
and your morphologic variabilities high
there's almost a two-fold increased risk
of death more importantly if you're put
into this low-risk subgroup with
physician would normally say okay well I
shouldn't do too much because your risk
is relatively low to begin with if your
morphologic variability is high you're
at almost a two a three-fold risk
increase increased risk of death so I
think that you might the point here is
that you can combine these very low
costs easily obtain information apply
subtle algorithms founded in signal
principles of signal processing
artificial intelligence to be able to
dissect information that are quite
powerful for making statements about the
future cardiovascular health of the
patient so now I'm gonna turn to what's
called the microscopic challenge and a
microscopic challenge is sort of not
looking at information that's obtained
from the patient as a whole but looking
at the path of physiologic processes
that are involved in heart attacks so
what happens when you have major heart
attacks so the person who's walking down
the street and he or she has chest pain
and falls over and drops dead what's
what's the process that happens there
well here's our very mature a gentleman
here who's grasping his chest because he
has discomfort and if you look at the
heart at this point in time there's a
blockage within a vessel that feeds the
heart that blockage actually breaks open
it's called plaque rupture
the clot forms in the vessel and then
blood cannot flow through that vessel
anymore and the heart dies there are and
this is so the microscopic challenge
here I would say used to visualize and
understand the early events that
precipitate heart attacks and there's
some very interesting work happening
from with my colleague Brett Booma on
Mass General Hospital and he's a HST MIT
affiliated faculty member you can get
very precise and pristine images of
coronary arteries early on in the
process and you can see places where
there are lipid Laden areas filled with
cholesterol places with calcium and and
so forth so that's one part of the
challenge that I think would be part of
the future these types of studies I
think will become routine in a not so
distant future let's look at even a
smaller level of detail so we can look
at the vessel we can look at the
athletic erotic lesions within the
vessel but this process as I said
involves these plaques that are within
the vessel and they rupture so this is
actually a specimen taken from a patient
who died from a catastrophic heart
attack and this is an Atlas chaotic
plaque here and over it this is covering
this lining of collagen which ruptures
and when it ruptures the blood with
inside the lumen of the vessel comes
into contact with all of this bad stuff
and the clot forms and you can see this
clot takes up a lot of room so that
before this clot was there you had blood
flowing through this entire region and
after the clot is formed you have blood
which is now limited to a smaller area
when you blow this area up where the
collagen has been degraded there are
lots of inflammatory cells these
inflammatory cells secrete enzymes which
degrade the collagen now collagen when
you when you look at it if you remember
from your biochemistry textbooks it's a
very rigid molecule for those of you who
had who took biochemistry I should say
but in the principle that I want to to
articulate is that collagen is like a
steel rod it's a very it's a very strong
metal so saying that enzymes are able to
degrade collagen at least looking at the
structures of collagen as they appear in
structural databases doesn't make sense
it's like a man with a with a hammer
trying to break down the Stata Center
but what happens is that so the
structures of collagen I have lost my
batteries so the structure of collagen
that we look at under in these databases
were obtained on the conditions that are
far from physiologic so the question is
how can we obtain accurate pictures of
this structure in a physiologic
condition and this is where computation
can play a role and here this is where a
lot of these methods these molecular
dynamics simulations and again I should
say a lot of these long time simulations
have been pioneered by David Shaw who
will be the next speaker you can get an
estimate of how the molecule moves just
by solving Newton's equations of motions
for particular molecules and when you do
that for collagen what you find is that
collagen actually it really isn't like
this this very stiff rod that you see in
crystal structures it's very floppy
right at least that's what the
simulations would say and this floppy
molecule is a dominant structure
physiologic temperatures most people in
the Northeast are thirty seven degrees
Celsius and at that temperature you'll
find that most of the way and you know
when I get that when I go to Indiana
people boo me when I give that joke but
people usually laughs in Massachusetts
without much in any case so it's very
floppy and this is the stuff that the
enzymes can degrade very readily so
there really is no problem the
simulations have revealed that there
that you know plaque rupture and stuff
should happen because the collagen
itself is so floppy it's done normal
time so this call this gives us a new
paradigm for drug design so if you think
about collagen is flipping between two
different states
a state that's very rigid hard to
degrade and a state that's floppy that
can be degraded easily and you look at
the enzyme which degrades collagen the
degradation process proceeds as follows
the enzyme binds near this floppy region
it attaches and it Cleaves it drug
companies have tried to develop
molecules that present that prevent this
process that prevent this process as
well but here here's a new Avenue how
can you prevent these transitions from
collagen going from it's very rigid
structure that
is not able to be cleaved to this
relatively floppy region and so I think
that computation has a role in helping
us understand these things at very a
very high resolution I know that I'm out
of time so I'll just close very quickly
computation I think has improved I
ability to diagnose heart disease and to
prognosticate
a myriad of avenues where competition
can improve our ability to analyze large
data sets that have prognostic value and
I think there's a lot of avenues here in
the future for computation and lastly I
think novel techniques including
molecular simulations to look at the
movement of small molecules under
conditions that are near physiologic
conditions can provide new insights into
the pathogenesis of cardiovascular
disease and I won't take up any more
time I just wanted to talk about some of
the people who've contributed to some of
this work on the MIT side and the names
you can see thank you
[Applause]
so I had a question for you you know
some people now are believing that they
should be publishing their genomes and
that that actually is a normative thing
to do and I'm wondering whether don't
you think in the future as these devices
get smaller and smaller people are going
to be motivated publish a lot of their
biometric data because of course right
now we're primarily gathering those data
from people that are at risk yeah so I
think the same issues that surround
publishing the genome surround
publishing biometric data as well you
know if your insurance company gets gets
some information that you are at
increased risk of let's say kids are
based on certain your genetic profile or
based on these biometric data that
you're an increased risk of having a
heart attack they may have ramifications
for employment as well as for insurance
now things I think are changing with
this new healthcare law that's 2,000
pages long that I'm not quite sure I
understand but but nevertheless those
are those are those are those are my
concerns
[Applause]